hello my name is John Perschke and I'm
John Pacey and we work on the Wolfram
cloud project and today we're going to
talk about cloud notebooks what you can
do with them and the progress we've made
over the last year
hello and welcome my name is John push
co and together with John Pacey we're
going to talk about cloud notebooks
today you might have heard about cloud
notebooks already the basic idea is to
bring the full power of mathematical
notebooks to the web so what we want to
do is render clouds render notebooks in
a web browser without having to install
any plugin or any other local software
and also make them interactive by
running in the cloud just to give a
little overview how this fits into the
whole ecosystem of the Wolfram cloud
because I think sometimes there's some
confusion about that cloud notebooks are
certainly a very central aspect of the
cloud but there's no they're not only
they're not the only part of the cloud
and there's multiple aspects of cloud
notebooks so first of all they're a type
of deployment you can think of cloud
notebooks as sort of another form of
CDF's where you take some interactive
content and deploy that into the cloud
but there's also other forms of
deployments in the cloud of course
there's form functions that allow you to
easily create web forms there's API
functions that gives you sort of lower
level control over server-side
programming there's also scheduled tasks
and many other things that you can do
with the Wolfram cloud but besides being
a form of deployment cloud notebooks are
also a way to deploy other things into
the cloud um you know when you execute
something like cloud deploy you can do
that in a cloud notebook but you can
also do that on desktop or in in desktop
mathematica that's just another form to
get stuff into the cloud so to say or
maybe you don't care about deployments
at all at all and then cloud notebooks
can just be another way to work
like like you do in mathematica where
you make your evaluations your
computations in notebooks in the cloud
in this case and you look at your
results and make certain conclusions
from that so so cloud notebooks can be
so the products that you care about
their can be the way to create the
product or maybe you don't care about
the product really and you just want to
work like it like in Mathematica it's
slightly different use cases but the
underlying technology is always the same
it's this this idea of rendering
interactive notebooks in a web browser
so let's let's look at this how this how
this works tonight probably increase the
zoom level here with can you see this so
this is actually already running in a
web browser this is a cloud notebook
it's just in in full screen right now
but you see it's just my Chrome browser
running and the notebook is in slideshow
mode that's why why it looks this way
but otherwise this is exactly what you
would get in the world from cloud with
the cloud notebook and as you might
might know from desktop this is this is
the familiar notebook interface where
you can you know enter stuff hit shift
enter it does your computation in a in a
kernel that's running in the cloud and
that's also where this notebook is
stored of course but the interfaces is
all in in my local web browser so you
can do simple math like that or more
sophisticated things like integrations
and and you see we spend some effort
getting nice typesetting to work in web
browsers it's it's quite challenging and
it's not perfect yet but it's it's
constantly getting better and besides
the static output you you also have
interactive content in notebooks of
course so you can with the Wolfram
language create a button like here and
then when you click it it does something
in this
case just print another cell but but
these are sort of the building blocks of
our arbitrarily sophisticated user
interfaces and one very important aspect
of notebooks is of course graphics and
that's what John is going to talk about
some more okay can people still hear me
all right so as a yawn introduced me I'm
John pacing and I also work on the cloud
notebooks and particularly i'm
responsible for graphics so again if
you're not familiar with desktop
Mathematica there's a symbolic graphics
language which is quite nice to describe
and do lots of things for a particular
in particular plotting so here again
it's a kind of a simple example of 2d
graphics to show you that that this is
you know rendered in a web browser kind
of natively okay it's not an image here
so we can do resizing and again later on
the talk I can get more into kind of
specifics but just to show you that the
way we implemented this at kind of the
box level we're in the notebook level so
in this case it's not just graphics that
works but anything that typeset says as
graphics box so in this case of a plot
and some other things so here's another
kind of quick example of a graph plot
and this one I wanted to show you
because if you seen this in desktop if
you hover over the the points you get
you get tooltips so again we've done
this in a way that just kind of flows
naturally from from regular notebooks so
I don't want to get too much into that
but there's graphics there's also
graphics 3d so this is a quite an
interesting an interesting case because
we have WebGL so it's a way to access
your a graphics card via the web browser
so we can do cool things like rotation
it's WebGL so it's a opengl speck in the
web so so again this is in a web browser
it's getting access to your graphics
card the jason is cringing at the at the
artifacts there but anyway sure could be
it could be maybe a minute yeah yeah sir
but anyway Jorgen just kind of to show
you examples that this this is working
in the in a web browser so again I if I
could use two fingers I can show you
that you can zoom and pan and lots of
things here so and again it's done in
such a way to kind of flow through at
the kind of box level so then everything
kind of goes through here get there so
yeah so here's our nice little caffeine
talk which is which is interactive so
that's kind of graphics another kind of
core feature of notebooks is manipulate
and you may have seen this before
working in cloud notebooks but in the
last year we've done quite a lot of work
to improve performance so again in this
case it's it's doing as much as possible
in the client side and then we still do
go back to the server for updating
graphics go through a few more examples
to note that again this this is fully
featured in this case it's a 3d graphic
you can still rotate it inside of here
and swap it around so it's quite
interesting
more again we have animation working
this kind of neat example so again night
not quite reaching the the performance
of desktop still still quite good so
hopefully eventually that'll be your
face when you're rendering all your
notebooks in the cloud so that's that's
the goal so right I'm going to pass it
back over to yon he's going to talk
about dynamic okay so as you might know
dynamic is sort of the underlying
low-level feature that powers manipulate
sorry okay um I'll try it lower so
dynamic is easily the underlying feature
that powers manipulates and all sorts of
other interactive features in notebooks
and so in its its most simplest form you
have dynamic of something and then later
when you bend that something changes are
the displayed form of the dynamic
updates correspondingly there's a lot of
other features of dynamic and we made
most of them work in the cloud notebooks
in the meanwhile one thing that we just
added support for quite recently is for
instance dynamic of current image
there's sort of two steps to this one
was to make current image work by adding
another form of communication where the
kernel can ask for the current image
from the browser basically and then we
also had to make this this self-updating
dynamic work so if I now execute this
yeah when you do it the first time your
browser will ask you whether you
actually want to allow this website to
use the camera but after that it will
just work and you see it's an émigré
updating as it should again it's not as
smooth
good as dynamic of current dimension
desktop and the main reason is that
there is more overhead and more latency
between the web browser and the servant
and the colonel here but it's so working
quite well J silly that and again the
the underlying dynamic feature that's
been used here is this self-updating or
self triggering dynamic where you start
with some variable and then as you
display the dynamic it it updates itself
which causes yet another render pass of
the dynamic and so on right so it was
one of the new things just want to go
over a couple of other new features that
we added during it last year one of them
is multiple undo and redo in a very
primitive form i have to say especially
when you compared to desktop mathematica
but what we did add support for is
undoing deletions additions and also
edits of cells so if i add a cell here
then add another cell and then i delete
this one and a now press command-c i can
undo all of these things and also redo
of course come on shift see things
replay again and i think being able to
undo just deletions of cells that that's
something it's really very useful but
other things like undoing evaluations or
style changes lots of other interactions
with the with the notebook that's not
implemented yet would require a bit more
sophisticated implementation like on
desktop but that's that's a start at
least so yeah if i evaluate a cell and
then press command-c it will undo this
it is added and this edition of the cell
but not the evaluation
another thing that we've been working on
is copy and paste so now you can copy
graphics for instance if I value at this
and then take the cell and now copy this
and what you might sometimes see is this
little extra dialogue that says data
ready to copy might be a bit unusual but
what's going on is that when you render
graphics initially in a cloud notebook
it doesn't have all the data that it
needs to copy to the clap to the
clipboard right away it sort of has only
an SVG like representation but what we
want to copy to the clipboard is really
the underlying box structure of the of
the graphics so the first time you take
such a such a graphics and copy to the
clipboard it will fetch that data from
the server and then you just need to
press command-c again or press this
little button because of basically
sandbox restrictions in the browser that
wouldn't let us modify modify the
clipboard without the an immediate user
interaction so that's just a little
restriction but once you have that you
can paste it here in another input cell
and this will work just like any other
graphics it's it's still a work in
progress this all copy and paste story
so for instance copy and paste between
cloud and desktop is not as good as it
as it should be it's a bit tricky and at
least the direction from cloud to
desktop I think that that will be able
to to improve pretty soon the other
direction is we will require even more
work also on the desktop side but we're
definitely making progress another
little useful feature is a shortcut to
enter lists you might have experiences
in in desktop mathematica it simply
means that when i press the star key or
shift aight on my keyboard it will
create a new item cell you know if when
i press enter it will create a new item
self so when you're working on on
documents often involve list this is
very
a very useful thing because if you don't
have to go through a bunch of menus just
too great an item so there would also be
this feature when you press tab it it
changes the indentation of the list but
that's actually disabled in this
slideshow stylesheet otherwise this
would work as well another thing not
notebook dialogues that's actually
building on the same principle that the
current image used as well and what this
allows you to do is things the things
like input where you know it brings up a
dialog in this case it's a lightbox in
your web browser if you call it so it's
still the same web page not a new window
but just a thing floating on top of your
notebook in the same browser tab and
here you could enter an expression and
you get it back as the result of that
Colonel evaluation
ah that is not possible I to remind
myself if you know it's just completely
interactive inactive but we're
considering to support our palates as
well and that that might be the answer
to that so that would be something that
sort of floats on the side while the
main notebook would still be interactive
and you could interact with both
notebooks at the same time
that's right yeah it's a bit different
here yeah I mean if that's important for
some use cases we could so we could
consider I think usually when you have a
dialogue that that's what you want you
want that to be in the in the center
until until you close it and of course
it's you can also create more custom
dialogues not only this input dialog but
but basically you open this dialog and
you completely completely control what
this notebook that's rendered in here
looks like you can have custom cells and
then a button to close it look here I
wanted to talk a little bit about what's
going on under the hood because we've
made some some changes to this over the
last year particularly motivated by
performance improvements probably won't
going to do too much detail but what we
what we did is basically a completely
new approach to how notebook elements
are implemented both cells and boxes and
so we created this new the general
framework to define encapsulated
components such as thousand boxes that
can that define how they behave by their
render method so if any of you know the
the web framework react to JavaScript
library this was actually inspired by by
react and it for some things we still
use react but but it allows for more
custom control of how we render things
for instance in in cloud notebooks we
need to be able to completely control
the positioning and the layout of all
the elements on the page that's
something that you usually don't get in
in plain HTML and CSS for instance to
have custom line breaking in notebooks I
I said I won't go into too much detail
that the nice thing that this allowed us
to do is is to write code in a in a more
functional and
and less imperative way which is pretty
much like the Wolfram language itself
but that's also an encourage pattern for
you this should mean that the cloud
notebooks become faster especially the
render time of manipulates was was
improved a lot when you drag a slider or
something and and also more stable so
yeah that did that's that I said
performance improvements the sort of the
one thing that the remote improvements
were was was updating of manipulates for
instance but then there is still this
other question of what happens when you
initially load a notebook because it
takes a while you know for all the
JavaScript code that's necessary to
render the notebook to download and then
it needs to execute in the browser and
that can take a couple of seconds but of
course we wanted to have a at least the
initial impression of a notebook to come
up much faster so so what we do now is
we create this HTML cash for every
notebook that that's in the cloud and
it's basically just plain HTML with with
some CSS that doesn't need any
JavaScript and when you when you load a
notebook that's what you see immediately
so it can load quite fast and then in
the in the background all the JavaScript
is downloaded and when that's already
then the notebook becomes interactive
but at least you see something right
away I said this is basically generated
for for all notebooks in the cloud
something to keep in mind is that it's
it's usually only generated when you
close a notebook so when you edit a
notebook in in your web browser it will
only update the cache when you then also
close it and it also happens when you
upload a notebook from let's say desktop
mathematica I should also know that it's
not working completely perfect
yet so there are cases where a notebook
should have a cache but it doesn't but
but we're working on improving that
constantly of course and speaking of
floating things John going to talk a
little bit about graphics loading too so
the graphics is slightly different in
that we're not doing everything entirely
on the client side so if you notice
during the WebGL rendering that was
quite quite fast and smooth because
that's all happening in client side
there are certain things for graphics
that we can't do push all the way in the
client side we need to get more data
from the server and specifically the
server side front end so what happens is
when you when you're going to evaluate a
graphic that would require going back to
the server you know that wasn't super
obvious what was going on so we recently
introduced this kind of placeholder
behavior to kind of show you something
is going on and also to have an
approximate size of what that graphic is
going to be so I'll shut up and show you
because then it'll make a lot more sense
so in this case where we're artificially
entering a pause which it'll wait for so
here that's our loading indicator
approximately the size of what the
graphic will be we go back to the server
once we get it then you have in your
place a you're typically not going to
see that for graphics / 2d graphics
because we try to pre pre generate that
when you have shift enter currently for
3d graphics we always request that so
it's quite fast for this example if you
can see that we're always going to the
server to request data to render it for
3d once once we're there it's fine so
everything here is happening on the
client side but the initial and ending
ones aren't so here's a different
example for that so that's one small
improvement to kind of show you what's
going on is supposed to
for a notebook a lot of times the
feedback was you don't know what's going
on just waiting for something you know
switch back to Jana talk about deploying
notebooks
so just want to mention this briefly
because I don't think it's it's been
covered elsewhere in other talks the the
basic idea is of course that when you
have your your dynamic interface
typically manipulate there's an easy way
to get that into the cloud that the
function to use is of course cloud
deploy and you execute this you get back
a cloud object that contains the URL and
now this this manipulate is just running
in this in this cloud notebook well here
and this is now interactive and using a
cloud Colonel 22 updates the
manipulators as a practice lighter of
course something to keep in mind is
permissions so when I when I deploy
something to the plowed by default it's
only going to be private which means
that I only I been logged in into my
cloud account on the wolf empowered can
see this if you want other people to see
this and also be able to interact with
it then you need to change the
permissions can either do that at deploy
time as an option to plow deploy or you
can also do it after the fact by calling
set permissions to add permissions for
certain user groups there's also set
options where you can completely
override the permissions option to a
cloud object in this case I set it so
that everyone even unauthenticated users
can read and also interact with this
notebook also keep in mind that these
interactions they use a cloud kernel
which will which will use your cloud
credits as as things people interact
with the little notebook there's also a
more mean there's there's many functions
to interact with the cloud from from the
Wolfram language of a very low level
function would be to just copy a file
from your desktop computer to the cloud
and the function for that is copy file
called with this case a plain string to
denote a file on your local file system
and here the second argument is a cloud
object which means copy from the local
system to the cloud system it would also
work the other way around for instance
you give a cloud object first and copy
down to your to your local file system
once you have something in the cloud one
typical thing to do would be to embed
your you're deployed cloud notebook on
on a website for instance in know you
can use an iframe to embed it in a
website or on a wordpress blog or
whatever and one thing that we thought
would be nice is if you would still have
some control over the notebook from the
outer webpage so we developed this API
that you can use to reach into a
notebook embedded on a web page from
javascript running on the outer page and
we've been using this API for quite a
while now at least internally for
instance the wood from cloud mobile app
is making use of this API but I think at
this point it's it's quite stable and so
we want to share this with you and at
least get some some feedback on how we
should extend this and then how this is
useful so to give you a little demo arm
was super for one thing we we added just
recently is it allows you to control the
variable in a dynamic module my notice
or not that I'm a dynamic module is sort
of the the underlying construct used by
manipulate so whenever you have a
manipulate it uses dynamic is used as a
dynamic module to to wrap to create a
local variable for for things like the X
here so you know I have and I'll have
this HTML page and I'm in full control
over this HTML you know
look at the source and then I just wrote
all of this but then i have this iframe
here to embed the cloud notebook as well
and what i can do now is I can also
create a button that executes some
JavaScript and in this case it will ask
me for value and now I can enter
something and it will talk to the cloud
notebook which will then update its
state accordingly also implemented
another function that just continuously
updates the variable in steps and so you
get this this animation which you could
also get from within the Wolfram
language and usually that's that's the
preferred way to do it but you know if
for some reason you have an outer
website that's already defined like the
web platform or whatever and you just
want a little notebook embedded in there
then this can be very useful I think
sure
so I'm sure how much I should go into
detail here but I have this little
helper module that just wrapped some
some of the technicalities of
interaction between the two browser
windows and then it's just a matter of
you know calling an API method on that
yep
so what what happens here is or if
there's a question but what happens here
is it it you passing the idea of a cell
so you need to have a handle of a cell
and there's another function to
enumerate all the cells in a notebook
and then you're passing the idea of that
and then it just takes the top most
dynamic module in that cell right it's a
dynamic module yep absolutely we could
make this more fine-grained maybe in the
future so that you can you know reach
into arbitrary boxes but but analysis
the top level manipulate in this case
[Music]
ah that is not possible but that's
that's exactly the sort of feedback I'm
looking for that could be a useful thing
right now it's sort of assuming that you
know what you deployed and so you know
the variable name and if you give a one
that's not existing then then it will
just give you back an error but if you
want to want to look at the details i
deployed this this documentation for
this API it lists out all all the
methods that you can call what the
parameters are and so on so and I would
love to get to get feedback on that as I
said it's not it's not completely you
know it's not about a completely
official API yet so things might change
but but I'm very confident that they
won't change too much
[Music]
yes are we do have events maybe not for
the things you just mentioned so there
there's an API method to add an event
listener to move on and then the events
that we have is for selection change
evaluation start evaluation stop and
some other things yep
oh you mean the thing we showed in the
beginning of what if we integrate that
is not directly possible fortunately of
what you can do you can you can take a
screenshot obviously what we do support
is I think so so if you you know if you
just look at it something like this here
this is just the browser rendering stuff
so when you select it you sort of depend
on the browser to what what it will copy
to the clipboard and that's not always a
very nice thing but what you can do is
here in the cell menu we have copy s and
maybe this doesn't like me in this in
the full screen mode it's weird what
they should show you is an option to
copy it as an image at least so yes
mm-hmm same idea
order that's a that's a very good point
so you know if the content is already in
the cloud and maybe the easiest thing to
do is just send a link to that cloud
notebook and actually interesting point
what we're also working on right now is
is having links to individual cells so
let's see if you have a very long
notebook and you care about the
particular cell then we'll have a way to
have an anchor for that particular cell
all right now we're almost at the end
anyway just wanted to mention this
document as well because that's one of
the things that I think we've always
been missing is is a better
documentation of what other things that
we expect to work in the cloud what are
the current limitations you know what
what do they expect to change and so
this this document here that you know
the link is in the is in a slideshow
notebook this is the start of getting
better at this so just rode up or some
of the things that you know common
pitfalls maybe some some of the
technical limitations and also some some
background information about how we do
certain things which which might be
interested you know reach certain
limitations that's that of course we're
constantly working on improving this
interface we're certainly aiming for
feature parity with the desktop products
but that's a long history to catch up
with so but some of the things that
we're trying to implement as well is the
spell checker for instance we're
constantly making improvements to the
type setting such as a spanning
characters and things like that they not
perfect yet but what getting better and
in general we just try to have complete
support for all the boxes which other
the low-level typesetting constructs and
their options but basically at a point
where
the options are all supported i did
sorry the boxes are supported but not of
not all of their options so that's the
new term goes further out in the future
is still the idea to be able to edit all
those typesetting constructs you know
when you have super script or grids in
destin mathematically there's a nice
editor for that we don't have that yet
in the cloud but the goal is certainly
to have that at some point and then also
life collaboration on notebooks that's
also another another big goal of us to
have two or more users editing a
notebook at the same time and seeing
their their edits in real time thank you
very much